okay good morning so today we do Islam
um some quick facts some questions that
we will look at today about uh theic
golden age uh the first major question
is while Europe was in its Dark
Ages uh Islam was embarked on its golden
age so the first question is how did
this happen why was there where why was
there there this
Divergence second question we're going
to look at is um what ended the Islamic
Golden Age why would this period come to
an end the third question we're going to
look at is eventually how did Christian
Europe overtake the Muslim
World um so those are the three big
questions we will look at in today's
class some quick facts about Islam
it is the world's second largest
religion uh Christianity has two billion
people Islam has 1 billion people uh
they are divided into two major sects
the Shia which is based primarily in
Iran and the Sunni uh which is uh
everywhere else uh the light green are
the Sunni people and the dark green are
the Shia people and as you can see uh
Islam extends all across Africa the
Middle East and Central Asia and into
India the most populous uh Muslim
country in the world is actually
Indonesia um the Shia and the Sunni the
only the only major difference is that
the Shia believe that only a direct
descendant of Muhammad's grandson Ali
can be the leader of the religion
whereas the Sunni do not believe this
now um this is a religion of 1 billion
people so there are many different
belief system many different sects
within this uh cosmology but um this is
really the major difference okay between
the Shia and the
Sunni um
so
Muslim means to submit yourself to God
to believe in God and to commit yourself
wholeheartedly to him and um Islam was
founded by a man named Muhammad who um
the Muslims consider the prophet of of
God the final prophet and Jesus was the
penultimate
prophet and um The Legend is that at AG
40 uh Muhammad who who is a merchant or
a Trader he has a vision he goes into a
cave to meditate and the Archangel
Gabriel visits him and reveals to him
certain visions that he has memorized
and these Visions become the basis for
the holy book of the Muslim um tradition
called the
Quran and he and um Muhammad understands
that his mission is to be a messenger of
God and to reveal the truth of God to
the Pagan Society in the Arabian world
so he's basically Mecca um and when he
tries to reveal a truth he is met with a
lot of resistance and eventually he's
forced out of Mecca and he goes to uh
Medina uh this is called the Hijra in
the Muslim tradition the
pilgrimage and when he goes to Medina um
he becomes the leader of the Waring
factions
within uh Medina primarily between the
pagans the Muslim tribes and the Jewish
tribe so there are three major factions
and um at this point Muhammad Chris call
the constitution of Medina which
promises religious freedom to everyone
within the Muslim
tradition okay so ever since the
beginning and this is very important the
religion of Islam was a open tolerant
and inclusive religion and they have
they have basically maintained this
tradition for the next Thousand
Years
okay
um eventually Islam will spread from the
araban desert to all across the Middle
East they will conquer the Persian
Empire and they will take at least half
of the bantin Empire including the
richest parts of the bis Empire which
are Syria and uh Egypt they will also
take Jerusalem where they will build
something called the AL aak Mount mosque
and Legend has it that
Muhammad um ascended to Heaven from this
place now what's really important for us
to remember about this place is the all
accept M it's still there in Jerusalem
and it is built on top of something
called The Temple Mount remember in the
year 70 the Romans burned down the
second temple of the Jews the holiest
site in the Jewish
faith and now and then the Muslims came
and built the axac mosque on top of the
Temple Mount now this is a very strange
thing to do if Muslim if the Muslim
tradition is open inclusive and tolerant
and Jews are welcome into the into into
the tradition why would you build a musk
on top of of the Jewish holy sight that
doesn't really make any sense and quite
honestly this has been a mystery to
everyone no one has been able to figure
this out okay so we will today attempt
to solve one the great mysteries in the
Islam tradition why was the aat mosque
built on top of the Jewish Temple Mount
okay um as I mentioned the Arabs will
expand from the desert of Arabia and
they will conquer the sassanian Persian
Empire and they will take at least half
of the byzantines okay they will try to
lay Siege on constantinopole but
remember that when we discuss the
Byzantine Empire Copo is designed as an
impenetrable Fortress so there there'll
be two major sieges and because of the
walls and because of Greek Fire um they
will be unable to take the
city um the spread of Islam was
lightning fast in L 100 years they
spread from the desert of Arabia really
the poorest place in this entire region
throughout most
of um the Middle East okay so the dark
green is where they started and the
light green is where they eventually um
expanded to and remember this process
takes less than 100 years which is
remarkable
um the the OM calipat was about 700 okay
so let's just compare the omaya calipat
with other Empires including the tongue
okay the tongue really is the height of
chin chinaese civilization but as you
can see the omantic calat um really is
the largest Empire in the world at this
time and eventually they will also
become the wealthiest Empire um at this
time um there are five pillars of Islam
it is an
extremely simple and clear religion when
compared with Christianity and Judaism
okay there are five pillars to the
religion um first of all you have to
believe that alab God is the only
God okay and this mirrors the Christian
and the Jewish faith um you are required
to pray at least five times a day facing
the direction of uh
Mecca you must give uh money to the
poor um you must fast during the holy
days the last thing is you must make
something called the Haj which is a
pilgrimage to the holy site in Mecca and
perform rituals in Mecca this is
something that um all Muslims must do
and you will have the poorest Muslims
they will save uh their entire lives
just so that they could make this harsh
okay the Muslim people are probably the
most devout uh the most religious people
you will meet they take their religion
very very
seriously this is the in Mecca and um I
was actually in Saudi Arabia and I tried
to go there and then I was told only
Muslims can go and and and so I was as
as a train station I I was trying to buy
a um ticket to Mecca and they said
what's your Muslim name like well I'm
not Muslim like well you can't go then
so I was disappointed uh but it is a
beautiful um absolutely one of the most
beautiful rituals in the world
today okay um so to summarize the
introduction there are three major
Mysteries to the history of Islam that
we still haven't really solved today
okay the first mystery
is um we know that they have something
called the con constitution of Medina we
also know that Jews who are literate
were part of the early movement of Islam
so why do we have we have no early
records for the first 100 years what the
first 100 Years of the movement that's
very very strange okay um another
strange question another strange um
thing is why would the Muslims go to war
against two major Empires the Romans and
the Persians that's kind of suicidal
they didn't know they were going to win
so why did they go to war okay that's
the first mystery we'll solve today
second mystery
is remember I said that the Shia and the
Sunni um have a major searan divide the
Shia believe that only the descendants
of of Muhammad's grandson Ali can be the
cff the leader of the Muslim people the
sunis don't so why didn't Muhammad just
name a successor and avoid the Civil
Wars that were erupt after his death the
third question uh is why was Al aat
built on the site of the Temple Mount
and this is still a problem today
because a lot of the
conflict uh in the Middle East is driven
by this problem where the Jews want to
rebuild the temp po uh but to do so they
would have to destroy the AL AAC mosque
which is the third holiest site in the
Islam world so this is a very important
question that is still relevant to us
today so we will also look at these
three mysteries and again no one knows
the answers to any of these three
questions and no one will ever know
because so much of the historical record
has been lost to us but I will try to
provide you with an
explanation okay given uh my
understanding of the Islamic World which
by the way is extremely limited okay so
uh please ask questions please challenge
me uh I'm looking at you Doug okay all
right all
right okay so today's topic is Islamic
Golden Age so let's just have a quick
look at the Golden Age um at the height
of uh Islamic influence there were a few
centers of incredible
cultural um creativity uh one such site
is bakara yakistan it's still there guys
you can get on a plane like Doug did and
visit it it is an incredible City I say
that without actually having visited it
but I I've heard ter terrific things
from Doug and you can go online as well
and look at videos but it is an
incredible City and it shows you the
immense creativity the artistic
creativity of this I'm golden age but
the
main cultural center of the Islamic
goldan age is
Baghdad okay it's not so beautiful now
but back then it was really the center
of the world um it's a round City and
it's a new
city um this is a um top topographical
map of the city as you can see it's
surrounded by the Tigers and Euphrates
and it is a round City okay one of the
few round cities of that
time
um Baghdad was the capital of the abased
calat which started the Islamic golden
age uh the abasa calipat is the
successor to the umad um Empire okay and
this is where the abasa calat
was and this is uh what what Muslims
consider the height of their
civilization um the thing that's really
important for us to understand about the
Abbasid uh Empire is that not only were
they influential in the Muslim world but
they event but they eventually would
come to create the world that we live in
today okay so when we think of
globalization we think of this as a
recent
phenomenon but look at the trade route
that the ambass calipat would create
over its 3 to 400 year history it
connects the ENT entire
world
okay um as I mentioned last semester
Global globalization has always existed
to a certain extent in world history but
the abases the Muslim religion would
would take these existing networks and
make them Rich a lot richer a lot more
dense and a lot faster okay so um you
may not know this but the aasad trated
heavily with the tong and the S
dynasties in fact it is the abases who
would initiate something called The
Maritime Silk Road the Overland Silk
Road has existed for a long time but it
is the abases who will eventually create
the maritime Silk Road and will bring
China into the world to a greater extent
than ever
before
okay so uh this is a
trade um the main Center for cultural
production uh in the Muslim world is
something called the house of wisdom and
it's
modeled um its model is the Library of
Alexandria okay remember last semester
we discussed the library of of
Alexandria in Egypt and its mission was
to be the first University to take all
istic knowledge and culture and
systemize it for um uh dissemination
okay and the House of Wisdom uh was
doing the same thing where it would take
all knowledge and culture within the
Islamic world and outside the Islamic
world and systemized and C cized for
Mass dissemination okay so um the things
that they were doing were they were they
were taking Hindu numerals okay so 0 1 2
3 we still use them today they took them
from India and again they standardized
it and disseminated this knowledge they
took works from Aristotle and Plato
translated into Arabic and Persian and
then disseminated it um the the main
contribution of the Islamic golden age
to World culture is in actually
mathematics okay so they took all the
math um in the Greek world and in the
Persian world and in the Hindu world and
then they would systemize it and then
build on top of it okay
um this is a rendition of the House of
Wisdom this is where the three major
creative civilizations would meet and
exchange ideas right the Greeks the Jews
and the Persians they would also take
ideas from the Indian tradition and the
Chinese tradition as
well um the major literature or literary
work that we still have today from the
Islamic golden age is the Arabian
Knights okay um Scholars have looked at
this very closely and most scholars
believe that these stories is actually
from
India also what's important for us to
understand is that at that at the time
this was translated it was actually not
that popular within the Muslim World
poetry philosophy mathematics science
were considered the high Arts this was
considered low Arts uh why we have it
today is that the Europeans would
discover this centuries after the
Islamic golden age and they fell in love
with these stories and that's why we
still have them today um and Disney
movies are based on on this as
well okay so so let's look at the some
of the major thinkers uh and
philosophers of this is Golden Age so at
this time in one history we don't
differentiate between philosophers
poets uh scientists mathematicians
okay all
intellectuals engage in all these
different fields okay so one most famous
is roomi who is Persian a poet a Mystic
a philosopher um um inin sinina is
probably the most famous intellectual of
the ISL Golden Age um his books his
Works were admired in Europe okay so the
Islamic the Islamic philosophy um was
being exported to Europe where where it
would have a major influence on many of
Europe's major thinkers you may have
heard a man named Leonardo Fibonacci you
should have heard heard of him in math
class well well at this particular time
in history he was going to Baghdad to
study from the leading mathematicians of
this time and taking their ideas and um
importing them all back to
Europe okay so this is iin s uh and the
Latin name is a
China um even rousa AOS is also um a
major intellectual at this time just to
show you how influential these two were
in Europe let's look at Dante's Divine
Comedy so Dante is in uh hell and there
in limbo he's meeting the most
influential the greatest philosophers in
human history who have influence
European civilization obviously he's
he's going to name Socrates and Plato
okay but guess what but he also
names AOS and aanti
okay so Dante is
acknowledging the debt Europeans have to
Islam this is important for us
because um the Muslim intellectual
influence on Europe has been whitewashed
from history this is something you do
not learn in in school usually but
without Islam you can make the argument
that Europe could not have modernized
Okay and later on I'll explain why
that's the
case um Omak Kayan is also another
famous um intellectual poet
philosopher um this is this man Musa Al
haami is considered the father of modern
day algebra his Latin name is algorithme
okay and if this sounds familiar it's
because his name will give us the Modern
English word algorithm both algebra and
algorithm were originally Arabic words
all right so most of the math you're
studying in school actually originated
during the Islamic Golden
Age um this name is alhazan and he
invented physics basically
Optics um again extremely influential
and again these ideas will be um import
it back to Europe and they will become
the basis of the Renaissance okay um Al
zahari is the father of surgery at this
time in world history uh the very best
hospitals are in the Islamic World by
far um this is the first um 24-hour
Hospital in Baghdad what's also amazing
about these hospitals is that if you
were poor and could not pay you could
receive receive medical treatment for
free that was just part of the faith all
poor were treated with great charity and
kindness um during the Islamic golden
age uh this is Al Kawa will again guys I
don't speak Arabic I I'm probably
butchering the the name but it was found
in 859 in Fest Morocco this is important
because this this is actually the first
degree granting University in the whole
world and it's still there guys okay
this is the oldest university in the
world what's also amazing is it was
founded by a woman who inherited a uh
Fortune from her father and she spent
all her money on building this
University all right Interruption if you
ever get a chance to go
to most
am absolutely Morocco is an amazing
country as well okay so um 58 the
Islamic Golden Age officially came to an
end or or that's what scholars believe
and the reason why is on 1258 the
Mongols will sack Baghdad and they will
burn all the books okay or or that's
what the legend tells us
Baghdad had an thriving bookstore
culture and this was this was unique in
the world um intellectuals or the elite
um they spent a lot of their resources
on buying books and they um imported
paper from China they learned how to
make paper from China so books were
extremely popular within the uh within
Baghdad okay especially among the elite
um as well because of the Quran it was
necessary for the elite to be litered it
was the man and of you to be U literate
and the Quran will also standardize
Arabic uh and make it the official
language of the entire uh Muslim World
okay but just because the Islamic Golden
Age ended does not mean that creativ
stopped in the Muslim world this is iben
Cen and he is considered the father of
social science okay e
economics um quantive history politics
this man um invented a lot of these
disciplines he is most famous for his
idea of asaba which is means social
cohesion so he was actually the first um
to systematically think about Grand
history why do civilizations why do
civilizations rise and why do they
Decline and his conclusion is that the
Borderlands are able to conquer Empires
because
uh the Borderlands the people there have
asaba which just means that they are
more egalitarian more free more cohesive
as a culture whereas the Empire because
it's so big it loses a lot of cohesion
okay um and again uh even Coden is a
major inspiration for the history that I
try as well
from 1300 to 1700 the world be dominated
by three major Empires the Ottomans the
saats in Iran and the Mongols in uh
India they are collectively known as the
uh gunpow
Empires so what's amazing is since um
its Inception about
622 up until the year
1700 the Islamic religion dominated the
world and so the question for us is why
was that the case how did Islam overtake
Europe and overtake Christianity okay
that is a mystery in question for us
today that we will look at okay so let's
go back to the three mysteries that I
introduced um earlier why do we have no
written records even though we know that
the people within the movement Jews and
Christians knew how to read and write
okay that's the first question second
question is is why did Muhammad name a
successor the third question
is why was the alasa MOs built on top of
the Temple Mount okay
so um this this is a paradox because
Jews were an extremely important part of
that early movement right so why why why
would you offend the Jews like this
right okay to understand what happened
okay let's go back in
time and we know that in 622 Muhammad
goes to Medina and that's what starts
the um Islamic movement but let's just
go over to Jerusalem and figure out
what's happening there and once we do
that then we're able to figure out
what's going on in that world it turns
out that in 6 622 there's a major war
going on between the two major Powers at
this time the Persians and the
byzantines and it is a deadly war that
is engulfing the entire Middle East okay
so this is from w wikipedia all right
now guys um never trust Wikipedia as a
historical Source but it's useful for us
to understand what contemporary
historians think okay so this this is
from
Wikipedia the Jews have aligned
themselves with the Persians why because
first of all the Romans control
Jerusalem and in the year 70 the Romans
burned down their Temple and in the year
135 the Romans expelled the Jews from
Jerusalem their holy city so ever since
then the Jews obviously they want
revenge but they also want to return to
their holy city and rebuild the um
Temple and with the Persians they saw
this as an opportunity because
historically the Persian and the Jews
have gone along very well okay so the
Jews helped the
Persians take Jerusalem and and push out
the byzantines but when that happens the
Christians in Jerusalem they
revolt and they force out the Jews and
then the byzantines under their Emperor
herac leus they return to Jerusalem in
the First Crusade okay this is the
beginning of the idea of crusade and
they retake the city and then what they
do
is they expel the Jews from judism
obviously but
then they start
to kill a lot of
Jews okay and they force these Jews
outside of Jerusalem so
now these Jews have nowhere to go but
there's something called con
constitution of Medina in Arabia
right there is a prophet Muhammad who is
promising religious tolerance for all
all can practice their faith in peace
right so it makes sense for a lot of
these Jews not all of them but a lot of
them to join this early movement what's
important for us to understand is that
at this point M Islam Muslim is not a
distinct
religion okay all these people are
called Believers because Muhammad
himself as the final messenger of
God
okay Abraham was the first then you had
Moses then you have Jesus and now
Muhammad is the very last so all these
three different Traditions the Christian
tradition the Jewish tradition and the
Islam tradition in the beginning were
all just one religion one idea which is
to bring God to Earth and make everyone
understand that God is the true God okay
to create monism on Earth that's the
origin of this new religion of
Islam okay and this is the constition
Medina which is in the Quran and which
we know to be historically true maybe
not not the wording okay but we know
that this existed and these
people were called Believers and also
this would also include uh people who
believe in
Zoroastrianism okay because zor aism was
also um a monotheistic religion so it
was so the C Medina was an attempt to
unite all monistic religions into one
single tradition that fought for God
okay also what's really important for us
to understand is um not only is there
all this persecution going on against
Jews and against Christians and against
zor aans okay but also this is a
apocalyptic St age where all three
Traditions believed this was literally
the end of the world if you were Jewish
you believe in a final battle called
aramon between the Messiah who would
lead you and against two enemies called
go and Magog okay guess what the
Persians and the Romans were funny each
other so you could easily interpret this
to mean the Persians and the Romans were
the gaw and magok enemy
in your tradition this will be the final
battle this is when Jerusalem is most
threatened well the Romans the
byzantines just took your city and
mastered your people so in the Jewish
tradition this is the end of days this
is the final battle and and the Messiah
would emerg to lead you to final victory
that person a lot of Jews could
interpret to be Muhammad okay for the
Jews this is the end of days but for
Christians okay they also believe
believe this is the end of days
because um there a final battle between
the
Antichrist and the Messiah okay the
Antichrist is obviously Heracles who is
the Emperor of the bises who've been
persecuting uh Ro Christians for a long
time remember uh the official religion
of the byzantines is the Holy Trinity
but most Christians didn't believe in
the Holy Trinity and they were
persecuted for uh the refusal to believe
in in the Holy Trinity okay so for
Christians this is also the final battle
zor Asians believe in the final battle
between good and evil okay so this is an
apocalyptic age where everyone believes
this is it the final battle Muhammad is
saying to everyone guys we're all one
people United by God and we are here
to fight for him okay and this is very
appealing for people
so the best evidence for my argument is
actually the Quran okay so again we
don't have any written records of
Muhammad but what we do believe is the
Quran um it is a collection of many of
Muhammad's original sayings that have
been redacted over time okay so let's
look some passages from the Quran to
better understand how Muhammad was
thinking and what he was preaching to
the Christians the Jews and the
zans all right oh people of the book by
this he means both the Christians and
the Jews okay why do you argue about
Abraham when the Torah and the gospel
were not revealed until after him will
you not reason okay so he's saying why
are we arguing about scripture why are
we arguing about belief we all
acknowledge that Abraham is our
forefather
okay and Abraham came before the Bible
it came before the Old Testament and the
New Testament so what's the argument
here you are you argue about things you
know but why do you argue about things
you do not know Allah knows and you do
not know Abraham was neither a Jew nor
nor a Christian but he was a monist a
muslim okay so this is what Muhammad is
saying a Muslim is someone who believes
in God as the only true God and that
includes Jews and Christians
and he was not of the polytheist
okay let's
also look at Muhammad responding to the
Christian tradition okay remember in the
Christian tradition a lot of conflict
arises from a debate over the nature of
Jesus and his relationship with
God okay and what Muhammad is saying is
guys the idea of Jesus makes no sense
Jesus cannot be God Jesus at best can
only be a messenger Meer of God just
like me and the idea that Jesus is is
God makes no sense Jesus was a human
just like me God is God he would he
would not represent himself through a
human okay and this and so let's let's
look at what he says they disbelieve
those who say Allah is the Messiah the
Son of Mary but the Messiah himself said
Messiah is Jesus right oh children of
Israel worship Allah my Lord and your
Lord he's making a clear distinction God
is my God I'm not God I'm not his son he
is
God whoever Associates others with Allah
Allah has forbidden him paradise and his
dwelling is the fire the wrongdoers have
no
saviors all right if you believe that
Jesus is God you are committing heresy
against the true God there can only be
one God there can't be two Gods
together they disbelieve those who say
all is a third of three but there is no
diety except the one God if they do not
refrain from what they say a painful
torment will befall those among them who
disbelieve so what he's saying this is
very important is that Muhammad is
saying the Holy Trinity the idea is just
nonsense they disbelief those who say
Allah is a third of three Allah cannot
be a third a fraction of anything he is
the one and
only okay
now in our time and we hear this we
don't really have emotional reaction but
Place yourself back in their time the
year
622 most Christians are being persecuted
for refusing to accept the Holy Trinity
as scripture because it makes no sense
we discussed this in class okay and now
but if you say it makes no sense you
could be killed okay you'll be
persecuted for sure and no and now
Muhammad saying you guys were right all
along you should believed in yourself
all along you were right all along okay
so let's use analogy let's just say for
example like the world government okay
we have a world government and for
whatever reason the world government
tells us the sky is red and you're like
wait a minute I know blue and I know red
and the sky is blue but if you say the
sky is blue you will be put in jail you
are not allowed to say the sky is blue
and then you have people teachers like
me telling you the reason why you
believe the sky is uh blue and not red
is your eyes lie to you you cannot trust
yourself you your eyes are defective
that's a problem with human beings we
can't trust what we
see okay and you have to go through life
believing the sky is red even though you
know in your heart it's blue but then
one day someone like a teacher says to
you in class actually guys we've been
lying to you all along the sky is blue
imagine your sense of
relief and empowerment and Liberation
when someone of authority actually tells
you what you've always believed okay
that's what Muhammad is doing Muhammad
is confirming to everyone that what they
believed what they knew about God was
right all along
okay so Muhammad's final message to the
people
is God is God and Only God and he is
everywhere and you can see him you can
touch him because he's everywhere and as
such you can feel him and he can be
inside of you okay and so this idea walk
occupy most of the Quran okay and this
is what he says with him are the keys of
the Unseen none knows them except he and
he knows everything on land and in the
sea not a leaf falls but he knows it and
there is not a single grain in the
darkness of Earth nor is there anything
wet or dry but is in a clear
record all right God is everywhere you
can see and touch him in
everything okay and so in other words
what's happening is that Islam is
really the first monistic religion in
the modern
sense
okay when we think of monism we're
actually think of the Islamic version of
monism All right so what is the power of
Islam and I want you guys to remember
this Islam is the power and beauty comes
from how Islam is able to unite two
major intellectual traditions in the
world the first is paganism right
remember the Vikings the Vikings told
stories they acted out rituals and
therefore there was an intimacy
concreteness and interconnectedness to
paganism that made us feel happy and
good okay it made us understand the
world it made us feel as though we could
influence the world that's the power of
paganism but Islam is doing the same
thing by making God concrete okay you
can feel God God is everywhere he knows
everything
but what Islam is also doing is he's
seeing the Simplicity Clarity and
absoluteness of monotheism okay
monotheism is nice because with monism
everything becomes clear to
you right okay there's one God therefore
I just have to follow him I just have to
believe in him there's like a million
gods in paganism so it's unclear what
you should do or how you should relate
to this million Gods but here in monism
the relationship between God and you
it's very very clear okay so in other
words Islam is a major intellectual
revolution in human history and we have
forgotten this because Islam the idea
has embedded itself into modity itself
okay does that make
sense all right so um what I will show
you the over the course of the semester
is that Islam really is the plal
modernity when we say that mity began in
Europe uh we forget that Islam really
built the basis for modernity okay all
right so fulfillment of the law and
prophit it's completing the story in the
Bible it's bringing God to to the people
you can now touch God you can now know
God that's the beginning of the idea of
protestantism okay and create heaven on
Earth and this is the idea of Science
Why do we use science to make the world
better because God wants us to make the
world
better all right so a lot of the ideas
that will underpin modernity that God
can be in us and that God expect expects
us to make the world better it's already
there in the beginnings of Islam and
that's why we will have the Islamic
golden age because they are
propelled by their devot to the one true
God is this clear to you guys any
questions so
far any questions so far all right so
let me very really quick answer the
three mysteries okay the first the first
problem is why were there no written
records um the answer is first of all
Islam marks a
revolution okay it is overturning the
social order the problem though is that
eventually Islam will become the social
order so you obviously don't want to
paint Muhammad as a
revolutionary okay that's the first
problem Muhammad um represented a
revolution against a social order all
right that's the first thing second
thing is
that we know that his early followers
the companions were all wiped out
they're all dead they all died the
official history says that they were
they died in military conflicts but
here's the amazing thing about early
Islam history we don't have that much
evidence of military conflict between
the Arabs and the Persians and the
byzantines we don't there's maybe one
city Cera where there was a there was a
Siege but a but we think that a lot of
the conquest happened um organically or
maybe um their enemy surrendered to them
rather than fight them okay and that
that's why that's why I would say it's a
revolution it's not a a it's not a con
it's not a conquest it's a revolution
where Ordinary People um were so
disgusted with the current leadership
that they opted for um a new a new
belief system
okay the problem though is that once you
amass
power and it's a coalition the question
then is who's now in charge so for
the next 1500 years there'll be a series
of Civil War to to to deter to determine
who will be in charge okay those early
companion were probably purged the word
we use is Purge they're wiped out
including the Jews and the Christians we
know for a fact that in the early days
of Islam Jews and Christians were part
of the
hierarchy um there's a man named St John
of Damascus who who was very famous and
he was a uh lead official in the omad
Cali of it okay we we know that as a
fact but eventually they were purged
from the system and if they're purged
what happens is they also Purge history
okay because if these are the companions
of Muhammad Christians and Jews then
they're legitimate they're more
legitimate than you are so therefore
they have to purge that
history okay but knowing that and the
third thing is that there will be a
series of continuous Civil Wars uh but
uh among the Arabs in order to to
determine who will the cff and obviously
they want to disguise this history they
want to disguise this history of civil
conflict okay so the first 100 years it
was revolutionary but it was also very
tumultuous and bloody and that's why
they had to disguise the first 100 Years
of um Islamic history right does that
make sense to you guys and again this is
my explanation I could be wrong all
right there there could be other
explanations yeah just throw in another
idea I think what you said doesn't
either one thing that's hard for us to
to imagine is that that our culture
would actually record its history
histography it seems to us as a given
know Chinese
culture official historians going back
for 2200 years and so on right um the
Greeks had their ancient histori the
Romans had their ancient hisor but not
every culture has historians the
Persians didn't write history right the
Indians didn't write history guessing
the um the Arabs didn't have a tradition
of writing down their History either
right so that this would actually be
recorded in sense that be familiar with
right probably was the case that is a
great point Thank you duck so so the so
Duck's point is
that um the of History comes to us from
the Greeks and the Romans who wrote
everything down okay but as duck says
there are many cultures who not believe
or do not they do not have institutions
to write down history we sort have take
it for granted today but back then it
was actually a pretty rare thing to
actually want to write down your history
okay so be and the good a good reason
why is that if you write down the
history you're also constrained by the
history right and and and that's why a
lot of Empires chose not write down
their history okay so so so thank you
okay all right second question is why
didn't Muhammad name a successor
again this is just my theory but if it's
the end of days if it's the end of the
world you don't need to name a successor
because God's coming right what's the
point in fact if you name a successor
then you are AIT defeat right what
Muhammad is saying to everyone is that
every of your Traditions Jewish
Christian zoram are right it's the end
of days God is coming there'll be peace
on the world therefore we will no longer
need leaders you won't need Muhammad I'm
the last prophet
man okay so that's that's why I think I
that's why I think he didn't name a
successor but there could be other
explanations
okay do do you do you have another
explanation okay now third is why did
they build the out a mosque on the
second temp on on the temple mouth and
this explanation is going to uh be very
controversial okay so the Jew support
the Persians in the war
against the byzantines on the condition
that the Persians would allow them to
return to Jerusalem but also on the
condition that that the Jews would be
allowed to rebuild their Temple which is
exactly what s the great did right s the
great is it's called the Messiah in the
Bible he he's the only foreign leader
called the Messiah in the Bible because
such the great allowed them to rebuild
the temple okay so what I'm saying is
this our aat MOS was originally the
Third
Temple it it is what the Arabs promised
the Jews for the
support but over time as these pures
happen as civil conflicts happen then
the Arabs needed to S consolidate their
Authority so they turn the third Tempo
into the AL AA mosque okay that's what I
think happened if you go into the I
don't have time to go into the very
detailed history of how the all aset
mass was built but it was a process that
took about 200
years it's very possible dur during
these 20 years intentions
changed okay so again I I know this is
extremely controversial statement but I
think that's what happened originally it
was meant to be the third Temple but
then over time the Arab leaders changed
their minds and thought to themselves
that if we do this then we make um the
Jews into very powerful political entity
within the Muslim World
okay does that make sense to you
guys
right okay again like these are my
explanations uh it's my interpretation
this is not historical fact okay all
right now now that we've done the three
mysteries let's go back to the three
original questions first question is why
did Islam enter its golden age and
Christian Europe enter its Dark Age
second question is why did the Islamic
golden age and third question is how did
Christian Europe overtake the Muslim
World okay to answer these three
questions all we have to do is compare
contrast these three major religions
together Judaism Christianity and Islam
right there are both strengths and
weaknesses to all religions so it's very
quickly compare contrast these three
major religions to see why they thrive
in a certain historical context so
Judaism the Bible uh it's a wonderful
piece of literature it has a very rich
history going back thousand years right
so the Jews were the first to have a
complete history of themselves
there are beautiful stories in the Bible
that still Inspire today the stories of
Adam and Eve the stories of the
Patriarchs the story of Moses they still
Inspire us today and they Inspire us to
create great literature and then you
have a literary culture so um the Jews
were expected to be people of the book
they were expected to be literate in
order to practice their religion okay
and this help helps helps us understand
uh why
Jews are sort dominant in uh Academia
universities in the media and in culture
and in the legal profession okay because
these are people of the book they have a
tremendous respect for Learning and for
literacy okay that said there are
certain problems with the tradition the
first is um it's contradictory when you
read the Bible it's always contradicting
itself okay um it's almost schizophrenic
you you could say it's very hard to pick
out a a definite message from the Bible
and that's why the old tradition uh
called a Torah is actually much more
important okay and so Jews have to go um
to the synagogue uh all the time where
the rabbi will explain to them the
meaning of the Bible because if you read
it by yourself it's almost impossible to
understand okay second problem is their
God Yahweh is's he's very problematic
he's extremely problematic as we know
from last semester when when we looked
at the Bible he doesn't seem to know
what he's doing and he's very very um
violent okay he he often commands the
Israelites to go kill all their enemies
okay so he's a very problematic
God the third major problem in the
tradition is um Faith ver versus history
if you believe that you are the chosen
people if you believe that Yahweh is
only true God then why are you being
persecuted all the time okay why why
were the Romans able to kick you out of
Jerusalem and burn on your temple which
is the house of God why are you homeless
why do you lack a Homeland okay and this
has been going on for Thousand
Years and there are no easy explanation
to any of these problems okay so within
the Jewish faith there's a lot of
conflict and debate and doubt
so the Christian faith was created in
many ways to try to resolve a lot of the
issues within the Jewish tradition the
first major advantage of the Christian
faith is it's the p plication and
Perfection of divinity right remember
how we said that Yahweh is problematic
well now we have Jesus who we can
understand and Jesus made the ultimate
sacrifice therefore we know him to be
the ultimate good okay second Advantage
is okay now that there's a person we can
for him deliver a consistent message of
being kind being merciful being
loving Okay the third Advantage is the
idea of progress of history eing is
leading to the return of Jesus the
second coming okay so you may suffer now
but don't worry because Jesus is is
returning and that will end history for
us all right so these are the advantages
of
Christianity but when you do that when
you have Jesus personified God you
create a lot of issues okay the first
issue is it's a really confusing story
why would God come down to earth
manifest himself as a human and then
sacrifice himself that's really really
confusing like I know there's a lot of
really good explanations as to why this
is the case still if you're just a
normal person you can't understand the
story it makes no sense to you okay
second
is that it's counterintuitive a lot of
the ideas in Christianity it's just
counterintuitive the Holy Trinity must
be the strangest idea in religion where
God the Holy Spirit and Jesus are
separate but equal it makes no intuitive
sense to
anyone the third is disent Divinity
okay God is out there somewhere you
don't know where you can't talk to him
you can't see him you have AB no idea
where he is okay it's a very distant
Divinity and so these are the
disadvantages of Christianity and so
Islam now makes sense because it's
trying to remedy and rectify these
failings of Christianity okay the first
is that it takes the Jewish tradition
and the Christian tradition and makes it
part of itself okay so it is really the
continuation and the perfection of the
Jewish Christian
tradition second
is the absoluteness of God okay this is
now
true monotheism where God is everywhere
and you can see him but if God is
everywhere then what's amazing is that
you can now that God can come inside you
through your faith through your devotion
and for your practice all right and so
what this means is you now know how to
behave in the world there's a Clarity of
purpose and action you know that as long
as you do those five things those five
pillars of
Islam your life will be good God is in
you and that gives you strength and
purpose and power
okay and this is these these ideas is
what will start the Islamic golden age
and allow Islam to propel itself past
everyone okay the problem though
is it's too simple and clear the
advantage of being contradictory is you
allow for different belief systems which
come in conflict with each other and
with this
contradiction and conflict it allows for
Innovation that's why C capitalism will
eventually will eventually give way to
process SYM
okay which is a
reinterpretation of the Bible but it's
because the Bible is so
contradictory that this Innovation is
about to happen the Bible was extremely
clear the Quran is extremely clear but
if that's the case then you cannot allow
for radical rejection of the past and
embrace of the Future
Okay second problem then is it it's
inflexible it can't be as Innovative as
Christianity and Judaism the third
problem is it Islam purports to stand
outside of History
okay Judaism is to be inside of History
Christianity is inside of history as
well but Islam is eternal when you read
the Quran it's meant to be the Eternal
words these words are always
true but then the problem then is how do
you go about and interpret
your actions through the lens of history
and how do you improve your Society
based on this
interpretation all
right so in the beginning the very
aspects the very strengths of of Islam
will give rise to a tremendous period of
creativity but over time um you will
have um the these Innovations will
become dogma and they will aify and they
will prevent further growth in Society
all right so does that make sense to you
guys all right so let me reframe what I
said in a different way all right so
let's just compare
sorry um let's sorry so I'm going to
compare and contrast Christianity with
um Islam so so and and and then and then
this will be a bit more clear to
you right
okay but are any questions before I
continue is this clear to you
guys so I apologize I'm making a lot of
generalizations but again this is a
macro view of of History all right so
let's look at let's look at
Christianity and compare it with Islam
all
right so as I have said um in previous
classes Christianity was developed by
the Roman Empire in order to co-op first
the Jews and
eventually um these Barbarian Invaders
and
therefore the religion is one of Empire
power
okay it's really about how to
control
people but Islam as I just mentioned it
is a revolutionary religion that must be
open and inclusive and tolerant in order
to attract as many followers as possible
all right now the main mechanism of
control uh for an Empire is the idea of
Orthodoxy Orthodoxy just means the
correct thinking okay but if you're
Orthodoxy then you have the idea of
heresy Orthodoxy is is with God heresy
is against God if you agree that the sky
is red because I say the sky is red then
you are Orthodox but if you insist the
sky is blue then it is her heretical
okay and that constrains or limits the
imagination
right and the philosopher that you base
your Society on is
Plato So the idea of the bishop the idea
of the Pope it's really the idea of
Plato's philosopher king all right so
I'll explain uh Plato's philosophy in a
bit in a second okay but but let's look
at Islam so it's a
revolutionary religion and therefore you
must activate the energy of all your
followers you must get them to believe
and you must get them to fight therefore
it's a religion based on
intuition God is with you you know God
God is inside you okay and the idea of
intuition is what allows for science you
can discover the truth by just observing
through empirical observation through
your own analysis through your own
belief okay and the person who argues
this is of course
Aristotle so this is the argument I'm
making you to you okay a lot of scholars
believe um the Islamic age happened
because the Islamic going the Islams had
books they had
wealth but the byzantines also had
access to all these uh major thinkers
Plato and Aristotle they all bis had a
lot of wealth okay what I'm arguing is
that a culture needs to have have a
attitude a perspective a worldview an
orientation for the byzantines and the
Europeans they chose
Plato but the Muslims chose Aristotle
and that is the major difference okay so
let's go over um let's summarize Plato
and
Aristotle how the philosophies different
okay for Plato the true God is called
the form of the
good the formula good is the beginning
of everything it is what is is immutable
that cannot be changed it is uh perfect
and is eternal Eternal means it's always
it was always there and it will always
be there the form of the good this God
he thinks and he emanates new Concepts
called ideals like
justice uh reason Beauty power okay and
these ideals will manifest themselves
into perfect forms
okay like a horse like a perfect horse
the perfect woman
okay this we can say is just
heaven we live in something called a
shadow World which is just an
imitation of heaven but it's a bad
imitation so everything sucks okay so
for example uh if you fall down and you
break your leg it hurts because we live
in the shadow world so in this
conception of the universe what we're
trying to do is
return
to uh the form of the good and for Plato
he argues that you can do this through
mathematics and geometry because
mathematics is what is most like the
form of the good it is it is immutable
perfect and eternal so by studying
mathematics and geometry you are able to
ascend back into the uh form of the good
but guess what
Augustine will take Plato and he will
adapt it to the Christian faith right
because how do you leave this world by
not sinning by having faith if you do
that then you are allowed to go to
heaven okay so in the platonic
Augustine understanding we in this world
just we all we have to do is not make a
mistake so do nothing okay do nothing
and you'll be
good
Aristotle has a different conception of
the universe he believes the formula of
good is called a prime
mover all right God is a prime mover so
God is the first thing that acts and
moves things okay and when he does that
when he creates
motion other things start to happen as
well okay okay so we're constantly
moving about where we're going is we are
seeking truth and it's called TS TS
means
purpose so each of us by our Nature has
a purpose if you're if you're a soldier
your purpose is to be the best warrior
if you're a mathematician your purpose
is to be the best mathematician okay and
that is the idea of Truth to fulfill
your purpose and therefore you must be
constantly acting okay now the the
beauty of this idea of motion is you can
now study it through empirical
observation you can observe things and
then start to understand their nature
and this gives rice the idea of
science
okay
right
so the Muslim world had a decidedly
arist Ian perspective whereas the
European world had a platonic
perspective now the great thing about
history the great thing about
civilization is that what will happen is
the Europeans will learn from the
Muslims they'll copy the Muslims
right they'll bring back
Aristotle they'll bring back
science uh and they'll bring back
intuition all right and they will do so
through three major events the first is
the
Renaissance where they bring back
Aristotle the second is a proess
Reformation where they will bring back
God remember the Catholic religion God
is aof God can only be understood
through the pope or the priest okay but
the Protestant religion is no God is
with us God is in us for your actions
you can um you can win God's favor okay
the last is science right the Scientific
Revolution and these are the three major
events that will give us
modernity okay but guess
what the Europeans are just
emulating the Muslims
but and this is really important they
will
improve
on the
Muslims okay so the problem with science
is yes in the beginning you will have
this all this trist Discovery but this
in
Innovation will eventually lead to
something called Dogma all right and so
what you need to do is create
institutions to destroy dogma and that's
what the Europeans will do which will
and this idea that Dharma can be
destroyed through discussion and debate
and Analysis is what will become a basis
of the S Revolution which will create
the modern world that we live in today
okay so we will go through all of these
three major uh movements in future
classes but please remember that it's
the Islamic Golden
Age which will inspire the
Europeans to to do all three of these
things which in turn will create the
modern world that we live in today and
that's why I believe that Islamic golden
age is really the IDE is really the
Proto modernity of human history all
right that is my argument to
you any
questions anything you are unclear
about was this
clear okay may I don't know if it's a
question or just just an observation
sure the U are you able to go back a
couple slides to the uh sure to the uh
Empire empire and power versus religion
okay sure right here yeah yeah yeah so
this is like one thing that you got me
thinking about the the years of Islam
and so there's kind of two movements
like the first one is like with the umad
calip which lasts about 100 years right
and it was really kind of that
Revolution that that you're talking
about like very expensive growth very
very quick um but it was also very eror
right it was done by the
ER okay and what what's really
interesting is like if we look at the
ab comes afterwards um as Mr Jen said
like it moves to B and right now that
and Iraq as an Arab place but at that
time it was persan okay and um by moving
there it it represents partly a a change
in culture and moving away from uh from
an Arab uh Homeland basically and
there's a whole bunch of there's an
amazing cultural openness um by moving
there there's contacts like you said
with um India um Central Asia um sorry
moves into Central Asia there's more
contacts with with China and so on and
there's a real cultural dynamicism going
on there and and Islam has to be very
open to those cultures and be inspired
by those cultures U um and engage with
them in in a pretty deep way right so in
some ways it's not just the the religion
that's the deciding factor for what
makes it a golden age but but just being
able to draw on so many different an and
Rich traditions in a way that say
theane or in Western Europe um you know
caths right yeah that's a great point so
um let me elaborate on on this point um
so there's a litter critic uh norford
fry right y Canadian right so so so so
norford fry is Canadian liter critic
okay and one thing that that he's
obssessed about is how literature is
developed okay when what he's observed
is there's certain moment in history
when great literature comes about and
that the moment is when a nation okay or
a people or
culture becomes an Empire okay and the
idea here is okay with a nation you have
tradition you have cohesion okay you
have a certain um uh literary basis
right and then when it becomes an Empire
it's forced to have a Vista it's it's
forced to have like a Global
Perspective and this change from a
nation a co coherent people into a conon
Empire at this stage in history um you
can it's possible for them to produce
great literature okay and there are many
examples of this so the first example of
course is Athens Athens is the um
civilization part
exelant right and so when did Athens
produce all its great
like literature well it was basically
the the Age of Pericles which lasted
from like you know 500 to about 400 okay
uh maybe 350 okay but it was not that
long and this is important because this
period is also when Athens which was a
you know a very small polish suddenly
became an Empire and it was this
transition that forced it to look
outwards okay so Athens is one example
but then of course you have uh King
David and the the Israelites and again
um after Bron collabs U David was able
to like create um an Israelite nation
and then conquer a l of this territory
okay so this these people now were a
small Empire they weren a great Empire
they were a small Empire okay and the
last example that we we have is
England right think of Shakespeare
when was Shakespeare ready around the
1600 okay and that was when England
which for the longest time was this poor
um island island was now becoming
emerging as a global Empire and with it
a CM poan perspective right so this is
the
pattern in history which picks up on on
Doug's point where um the new um
um Islamic empire when they shifted
their Capital to Baghdad they and they
now became a global Empire and as such
that to absorb all these different
traditions and cultures and become u a
multicultural Universal Empire okay all
right so nor fry has made this obser
observation um it sounds convincing I I
haven't I haven't done enough research
to fully buy into this Theory okay but
but he has made this argument and uh he
has made these observations with these
examples all right so thanks for that
okay any more
questions okay so um next class what
what we'll do
is the Middle Kingdom China Okay the
reason why is um at this stage in
history China is being brought into
world world
history and the reason why is the rise
of the Mongols okay so so next class
will be on the Middle Kingdom China and
after that we will do the
Mongols and then after that we will
return to Europe and do uh the Crusades
then we'll do the Renaissance the pro
Reformation theim Revolution okay